all right what do you got for me Mike
Hey brother can you hear me I can hear
you loud and clear awesome
um well firstly uh pleasure to be on the
show uh from Australia
um so just a bit of context behind my
questions so it is a two-part one and
you'll see why in a moment
um
so I'm 26. uh I run a company which does
about five mil a year in turnover
entrepreneur
um and I guess my question so sorry for
rambling a bit but part one yeah yeah
get to the point let's go
I've been me too right okay you know
involving the Big R I'm not gonna say
the word okay and it's really
um so part one of my question it's you
know a lot hundreds of thousands of
dollars on lawyers
Etc what do you mean by the Big R
uh I don't think I should say it on
YouTube me too
okay
can you type it in the private chat for
me just so I can yeah what what our word
you're talking about
so I've been accused of that oh got it
okay
and um yeah I guess it's you know I used
to be great
yeah I used to be quite uh confident in
that area of my life interacting with
women Etc
this has happened like I've just been
very
um that's hey man that's the new world
order that we live in I mean women can
destroy a man without any without any
kind of evidence proof it was that's the
exact scenario zero evidence by the way
this this is not [ __ ] new either like
I have a childhood friend that went from
New York working in the financial
segment to London and when I visited him
like 20 years ago his his place was
stacked full of hot models because
that's what these loaded you know
Financial you know District guys have
hanging around them all the time and
like I think it was
1995 or something like that he got me
too in 1995 so V2 is not a new
phenomenon it's been around for a while
um
yes so I guess my my question for you
the first question is what can I do
personally to
uh you know excel in that area of life
when it comes to relationships with
women because well definitely caused a
bit uh
internal you know an internal dilemma I
think a lot of guys kind of understand
that there's
a risk associated with dealing with
women in any capacity you know it's not
like even if you stay away for marriage
you still have risk exposure like a
woman can still destroy a guy that she's
not married to we already know this
so I think one of the first things you
got to do is you got to vet for red
flags
um yeah looking back this particular
person how many kind of you know I'm
gonna put my email list below get on my
email list if you're not on it I'll get
a good flag chapter for free so how many
red flags did this chick have
um I had only known her for about eight
hours okay so that was probably a bad
one to start with but I mean let's be
honest like you can spot the red flags
within the first eight hours you can
spot like the obvious ones anyway
probably three
three to four yeah so if you're seeing
three or four and eight hours there's
probably another three or four that
you'll see over the course of eight more
weeks you know dealing with it so so I
mean the first thing that you did wrong
was you you know you got intimate with
the chick that's got more red flags than
the Chinese Communist parade
um
right yeah I think that's definitely a
lesson which I've learned taking into
the future now
um I'll only you know look to actually
create any form of relationship be it
very short term or long term it's
someone that displays the opposite of um
red flags I think that's something after
some self-diagnosis I've realized I need
to do it for personal growth yeah
um yeah and that kind of
leads me into part two uh I would like
to link my profile for you to evaluate
but I'd rather it kept private is that
something we can do well if you put in a
private chat it's it's going to be seen
by everybody in the waiting area so if I
were like what do you want to send me
your Instagram or uh yeah just yeah so
go to my Instagram and DM me right now
I'll grab my phone I'll take a look at
whatever it is you want me to look at so
I'll just see it
uh would that be the unplugged Alpha
yeah
the
what is it that you want me to have a
look at
um well it's just I'm really trying to
maximize my life in all areas right now
finally is that you that just said hey
yes finances appearance relationship
just to you know as you say just excel
at my life in all areas okay
um yeah so I've set quite a high
standard for myself like I'm on
trajectory to be worth
eight figures by the time I'm 30 years
old
um you know like so I think I've got
finances sorted you got it all sorted
dude you've got you're [ __ ] jacked
you're good looking you're driving nice
cars you have a captivating life shown
on social media so what's the ask here
yeah well it's strange because I've
recently engaged in online dating since
that incident happened it kind of scared
me off real life for a bit but I haven't
really been having much success it could
be due to my location Australia the
country I'm not sure
um
looking for some general feedback as to
what I can really do to excel because I
do have very high standards for myself
like I'm worth a few million dollars at
my age and I don't think it's good
enough I don't know if that's a bad
thing or a good thing
Mike how tall are you
good question five nine okay so one
thing that that you never want to do
when you're posting photographs I mean
five nine is not short by any stretch of
the imagination it's like the average
height for the North American male or or
like any Western male but I just
wouldn't post photographs of you
standing beside taller people like
there's a photograph of you here
standing beside one of your mates it's a
tall Asian dude Asian guys aren't
generally taller than Caucasian guys so
it so it amplifies you know maybe this
guy ain't that tall so if you're using
that photograph on no I'm not dating
apps then that might be problematic for
you
um
so crop out the really tall guys would
be my advice because it because it makes
your height look more normalized when
you're standing around a bunch of other
guys
yeah okay and in general
um due to the nature of the company
which I run funnily enough it's on the
internet but I totally
flew from one end of the country to the
other to run this company
um and yeah I do not have any friends
but other people I work with so what
would your advice be in regards to
networking with you know do you own your
business yes why don't you find the
chapter in your city for entrepreneurs
organization and join it it's like 80
percent male they're all successful
entrepreneurs a lot of them are are are
plugged in betas all right like you'll
sit at a table and they'll be like well
you know happy wife happy life sort of
thing but you'll find the odd guy in the
group that's like a red pill Alpha you
know that you can probably befriend and
hang out with so that would be a place
that I would go to in the city that you
live at if there's a chapter for me oh
sign up for it I don't know it's a few
thousand dollars a year get into a forum
um it'll it'll certainly help your
business but it'll be a very good
Network like I'm still very good friends
with a lot of guys that I used to chill
with back in the year or Toronto right
um yeah no thanks for the advice yeah
um yeah so I guess just considering a
last question I'll let other people hop
in in a moment
um just what would your advice be for
someone like me I guess I'm when I
self-evaluate myself because I'm very
critical because I want all the success
of the world
um and I guess in terms of finances I
guess that's going reasonably well but
in terms of like other areas of
maximizing yourself as a man like what
would you suggest based on a brief
discussion what would you suggest that
I do work on because when I look at
myself internally I'm really happy I
think I think obviously like the most
important thing that we got to have a
conversation with is the fact that
you're dealing with hundreds of
thousands of dollars into a a false
charge a false great charge and that's
the result of you inviting crazy into
your life
um you don't look like you don't strike
me as a kind of guy that struggles with
um you know getting women into the
bedroom once they have an interest in
you right yeah not at all so so what's
who cares if it's Notch number you know
11 21 317 or or 2000 like like why like
why expose yourself to that risk for
like you know 20 seconds of a little uh
pleasure sort of thing like just like
don't don't do that thing again that
will make your life more easy lucrative
and fun you know for being honest
yeah no I definitely realize that after
this has happened to me
um that's definitely I'm no longer
looking for any
one night stand I'm sure you know what
that means
um that's an absolute zero percent
chance
um
but yeah I guess in terms of meeting the
types of you know females if we're
talking about that because I've got a
very strong network uh back in my
hometown of men uh not that strong in my
new city but in terms of females like
how would you go about meeting in real
life like what I'll tell you what Mike
you've you've asked some good questions
and I want to be respectful to other
guys that are waiting to come in and ask
some questions you clearly don't have a
problem with money there's there's a
link to my website if you go to my
website you can book me for private
consults and we can dive into it for
like half an hour to an hour you can
just book 30 minutes if you want it's up
to you yeah sure thing sounds good
awesome thanks very much thanks I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out